hello in this video i
explain everything to do with the ph value in a simple way
we start with the question
what the value is then come to the question
how do i interpret the ph value and
what is the difference between the p
value and the significance level  and
finally i will show you how you can easily calculate the p value
for different hypotheses test
online with data tab
to understand the ph value
let's first look at the
following example in this example
we would like to examine whether there is
a difference in the population  in the
income of women and men,
our hypothesis is that there is no
difference between the salary of
men and women in the population,
so we assume for the
first time that there is
no difference in the
income between women and men in the population
on the one hand  so we have
our population, but since it is not
possible to cover the entire population
questions
do we draw
a sample from this population at least it is of course
clear and
very likely that there is
a difference in
the salary of men and women
in the sample so although there is
actually no difference in the population there
will certainly be a sample between
the salary of  give women and men
at least a small
difference,
for example you can find out that
there is a difference of 50 euros in the salary
between women and men
in the sample or of 150 euros or that there is a difference in the sample
between the cold of women and men
There is 250 euros but
we still assume that
there is no difference in the total population, so our assumption
is that there is no
difference in salary between women
and men in the total population, and that brings
us to the p value the p value tells us  how
likely it is a random  whether to take a sample
in which the salary of
men and women differs by more than
50 euros although there is
actually no
difference in the population or how likely
it is to draw a sample
in which the salary of men and
women differs by more than 150
euros although  there is
actually no
difference in the population and the last the
last example how likely it is
to draw a sample
in which the salary of men and
women differs by more than 250
euros although there is
actually no
difference in the population, so here we are again
assume that there is a basic
overall difference the p value
now tells us how likely it is that
we draw a sample in which, for
example, the salary differs by 250
euros between men and
women
although there is
actually no difference in the total population  gives say
we have now used data tab and
d  ata tab has calculated for us that with
a difference of 250 euros pp value
eg 0.04
what would that mean, for example is
the value with a difference in
salary of 250 euros eg
0.04 it is only four percent
likely to be a random sample  draw
in which there is a difference of 250 euros or
more if there is
actually no
difference between the salary in the total population there
is only a four percent probability
that we draw a sample in which
the salary of men women differs by more
than 250 euros if the
the ph value is now of course very low
one can of course ask is it okay
at all the zero hypothesis was so it
is the case at all that there is
no difference in the population
or maybe there is a
difference in the population and
that brings us to the question  when
is it unlikely enough that the
null hypothesis will be rejected,
so when will the new one  Hypothesis
discarded for
this, the so-called
significant level also alpha level is
introduced. It is important that the
significant level is always determined before the
examination and may not
be changed afterwards in order to
then still receive the desired statements
in order to ensure a certain
comparability
that the significant level  usually
at 5 percent or at 1 percent with an
alpha of less than one percent
one speaks of highly significant of
alpha less than 0 5 one speaks of
significant everything that is greater than 5
percent is considered insignificant
so if we have a p value of
the  is less than five percent
we will discard the new hypothesis,
which means that in the end
the zero hypothesis
should be true, in five percent of all cases it happens
that we deviate more than the defined range
,
so in the end we make a
five percent error  if we
reject the hypothesis because  it could just
still be correct
so we come back to the
definition of the value the value indicates
the probability of the
observed result plus even more extreme
the results because the new
hypothesis is there if we look at it again
using our example if the  zero
hypothesis was is means here
assume that there is
no difference in salary in the population as a whole now
the fdp value indicates how likely it
is that we draw a sample and
in this sample the
salary difference is 250 euros or more
between women and men although
the  overall there is actually no
difference and now
I would like to show you again how he could
use the data tab to
calculate test de weert online for various hypotheses. For
this, please visit date up de and
then click on statistics calculator
in this table you can then create your
own  copy data in first
you have to copy the table le  rn
and can then copy your own data in
for our case if I
simply use the example if we
want to recalculate example 5 and just now
we want to compare income and
gender where can
I calculate a hypothesis test at all
in the end it is of course
this leader active square  test and
hannover
then you can also excuse correlation and
regression for our case
i click on the square of the nova
clique then the income
comes in to the variable and then the
variable gender and now
the independent perpetrator is automatically
calculated for me here i can see the
significance level above  enter what in
our case is simply 0.05 if
I then scroll down here is
a table with the value 2 pages
here I can read off the case that
0.09 or 0.02 comes out for the p
value depending on whether I am from  variance requires equality of
inequality but more in another video
that is what it says  in the end, in this case
, the difference in salary between
men and women is 650 euros. it is
now 82 percent likely that if
there is no
difference
in the population, we draw a random sample in which the salary differs by more than 650
euros because the p value is
greater than  0.05 is in this case
the new hypothesis is not discarded
but retained
now we could also
calculate other prosthesis tests in the same way, e.g. the
correlation analysis we can
look at there is a correlation
between age and weight
if we just scroll down  and
we see the values ​​for the
correlation here in the end we see
that age and weight correlate with 0.24
but this connection is
not significant because we have a pH value
of 0.45, i.e. 45 percent is
important to note
sigma 2 side is very often instead of peter, so
whenever
you see a table somewhere you see  that is equated
with the p will so I hope the video was right
today and see you next
time